My quarantine fad of choice
this last summer was gardening.
Among other things, I was
working with some basil,
and a friend of mine sent
me a recipe for pesto.
It turns out, they're one of
those good at cooking types.
So instead of talking
tablespoons or cups,
this recipe was all in grams.
Seeing that I don't
own a scale, I
realized that I had stumbled
upon a totally real world
definitely not contrived
need for machine learning.
I know how tall the plants
are, what species they
are, and some other yada
yada about the concentration
of some sort of chemical.
And I need to estimate
my basil mass.
Thankfully, the previous
tenant of 10 years
has been collecting
measurements on this same plot,
so I have some solid
data to work with.
So what's our strategy?
Maybe there's no need
for anything fancy,
we could start out with
a linear regression.
And maybe I'm the kind of fellow
that uses KNN in the regression
setting, we can run with that.
And maybe I'm feeling trendy,
and decide that my best
move is a neural network.
Or OK, hear me out.
What if I could figure out some
way to combine those outputs.
I want to come up with
some sort of model that
generates predictions
that are formed by each
of these constituent models.
This is the premise
behind ensembling.
Ensembling is a machine
learning technique
that has been shown to
increase predictive performance
in a variety of settings.
In a community survey
conducted over the summer
by the Tidymodels
team, we learned
that users felt
that the number one
priority for future
development in this ecosystem
should be ensembling.
This December, we are delighted
to announce the initial release
of stacks of package
for Tidymodels
aligned model ensembling.
When you're coding up
an ensemble of stacks,
most of the code
you'll end up writing
isn't specific to stacks at all.
I'll skip over the code
that generated these models,
but the gist is that
I've created three model
specifications here
using functionality
from the Tidymodel's core
packages like parsnip,
workflows, recipes, and tune.
The linear regression
spec here just defines
one model definition.
There aren't any hyper
parameters to tune.
For this KNN model
spec though, I'm
tuning over several possible
numbers of neighbors.
So this spec actually defines
four model definitions.
Finally, for this
neural network model,
I'm tuning over
six combinations
of numbers of hidden
layers and dropout rates.
So this spec defines
six model definitions.
And stacks each of these
11 model definitions
are called candidate members
or "candidates" for short.
These candidates are
the building blocks
for an ensemble.
The first step to putting
together a model stack
is the stacks
initialization function,
which works kind of like the
ggplot function from ggplot2.
It lays the foundation called
a data stack for the model
to be built on top of.
Now, the first core of urban
stacks is `add_candidates()`.
It takes in a
candidate and adds it.
We can iteratively call
the function as many times
as we need to add all
of the candidates.
Under the hood,
`add_candidates()` collects
predictions on a subset
of the training data
from each candidate.
And appends them as
columns to the data stack.
The second core verb
is `blend_predictions()`,
which fits a regularized
linear model on the data
stack predicting the
true outcome using
the predictions from each
of the candidate members.
We call the coefficients of
this linear model stacking
coefficients.
A stacking
coefficient of 0 means
that the predictions for
the relevant candidate
will not ultimately influence
the models stacks predictions.
Candidate members with
non-zero stacking coefficients
earn the title of
members, and we
can fit them on the
whole training data using
the fit member's function.
And that's it, the
output of fit members
is ready to predict on new data.
Fingers crossed that I'll
nail this pesto recipe.